donc il ya une cellule de blé améliorant
sur la droite puis à peu près 160 tonnes
de blé double améliorant donc doublé
très protéiné pour notamment des besoins
de la monnerie
julien thierry 32 ans est l'un des neuf
cent cinquante deux agriculteurs
implanté dans les yvelines
en 2015 le jeune homme décide de
s'installer avec ses parents dans leur
ferme de toussus le noble
il souhaite développer cette
exploitation de 300 hectares une
histoire de coeur c'est la ferme
familiale donc moi j'ai grandi ici
il ya aussi voilà il ya un historique
familial puisque mes grands parents mes
arrière grands parents ont cultivé ici
ça fait quand même plusieurs générations
qu'on est ici donc il ya un attachement
par rapport à ça sur ses terres
agricoles julien thiery et son équipe
récolte du blé du colza de l'orge du
maïs et de la betterave sucrière une
exploitation rendue possible grâce à la
fertilité du département on a des terres
notamment sur le plateau de saclay
c'est des terres qui sont très bonnes
c'est du limon profond donc des très
très bonnes terres sur lesquelles on
arrive effectivement avoir de bons
rendements
je savais en arrivant
on va dire ce qu'il y avait ce qu'il y
avait autour et le potentiel aussi de la
terre donc voilà je me suis installé en
toute connaissance de cause agriculteur
passionné par son territoire julien
thierry participent ce samedi 25 février
un forum consacré au développement de
l'agriculture un rendez vous où se sont
retrouvés les principaux exploitants du
département
c'était notre but en fait c'était de
pouvoir rassembler les personnes
d'univers différents
les faire se rencontrer qui est du
dialogue entre elles donc après la
présentation des diagnostics il ya pu y
avoir au moment de la table ronde donc
des échanges entre les agriculteurs les
associations on avait des élus présents
aussi des communes donc ça c'est très
intéressant pour nous aussi pour qu'ils
puissent prendre connaissance vraiment
de la part des agriculteurs et des
associations
l'événement a présenté un diagnostic de
la situation pour les exploitants des
douze communes de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines
les difficultés ont été abordés mais moi
je pense qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
solutions aussi d'initiatives qui
peuvent donner des idées d exemple à des
exemples notamment dans cette danse est
un bric à sion entre les producteurs
agriculteurs et les consommateurs
citoyens et moi je pense qu'il ya des
choses à développer la drogue dans ce
domaine une synthèse complète des
discussions abordées pendant le forum
sera rendu public dans les prochaines
semaines le résultat permettra notamment
d'enrichir les réunions à venir dans le
cadre du plan climat de saint quentin en
yvelines